[Music]
the government says it's a world leader
on the climate
but days away from a crucial summit to
persuade other countries to follow suit
questions about how it plans to lead
from the front
there is an urgent need to raise global
ambition
in reducing our emissions alok sharma is
the uk's business secretary
he's also the president of cop 26
the landmark global climate conference
to be hosted by the uk
next year the former climate secretary
amber rudd
who was at the heart of the uk's
commitment to the paris agreement
five years ago says there isn't enough
focus
now on the amount of diplomacy needed my
own view is that whoever's president of
the cop but aloc
absolutely could do a great job at this
should be doing nothing else
this is not a side hustle it is the most
important event taking place next year
so you can't be the business secretary
and be the president of cop 26. i worry
that he's got such a full entry at the
moment
he doesn't get his full attention he
would say and has said
that he's a really hard-working person i
know a little bit about a full agenda
at the top of government and however
hard you work there are only so many
hours
in the day i i think alot could be a
great president of cop
i just worried that he's also trying to
work with businesses while we're in the
middle of brexit
with businesses while we're in the
middle of covid there is so much going
on
we need somebody who does nothing else
on this
amber rudd also shares concerns raised
by a veteran climate strategist
about the lack of women in the prime
minister's cop team
the entire senior management team of the
the cop unit
is is is male except for one recent
appointee
they don't seem to have really grasped
the issue of gender
equality and that you know not having
the views
not having representation from half of
the world's population
isn't an inclusive look five years on
from paris
and new climate commitments are critical
the pressure
is on the uk to deliver them lisa
holland
sky news